[Music]
all right welcome to hannity as the
democrats are literally going
over the cliff politically they're
destroying themselves never stop them
by the way what we're seeing tonight is
the culmination of the pathetic
so-called resistance against president
trump it is backfiring big time
in the washington swamp lawmakers are
now set to vote on articles of
impeachment
it is the last meaningless step in what
has
been just a baseless political smear
against the president three years do
nothing democrats
the latest chapter in what has been a
desperate dishonest
non-stop effort well to undo a duly
elected president and take the president
down
impugn the will of his supporters we the
people and like every other attempt to
destroy president trump it is built on a
pack of lies
by a group of the most partisan hacks
that can never be trusted
the individuals now advocating for this
madness impeachment
were the very same people pushing the
russia russia russia collusion hoax
they were wrong four separate
investigations dead
wrong mueller report no collusion and
tonight
we're going to detail all of their lies
all of their corruption all the
individuals behind this
and we start with the hero of the deep
state oh the super patriot himself who
won't come on this program
jim comey he's been lying deceiving he
has formed the very
basis of the russia hoax what we now
know
everything we reported two and a half
years has been dead on
accurate in the fall of 2016 comey
signed off on the very first fisa
warrant application
against trump campaign associate carter
page remember it's one step two step
you get the page then you get into the
trump campaign transition
and as attorney general barr said deep
into the trump presidency
he signed that application he signed
three of them ultimately
he swore that the material provided was
true and accurate on the top of a fisa
application it says verified
it was unverifiable what he used the
overwhelming majority of information
was hillary clinton's dirty russian
dossier
and that was the first of many repulsive
lies
the application we now know relied on a
single source
second-hand information from christopher
steele
being paid by the clinton campaign in
the dnc
and comey's fisa application omitted
what they knew
that clinton paid for the material
comey's fisa application also admitted
that the material was not verified or
corroborated
oh well comey's fisa application also
admitted christopher steele had a severe
political bias against the president
there were numerous warnings he had not
to use this information
and subsequent renewals submitted by
comey omitted that steele's primary
subsource
the subsource the only source not even a
source
well he described his own evidence as uh
rumors hearsay speculation
uh accrued bar joke and he also admitted
that
the sub source even questioned steele's
credibility
wow and he intentionally admitted that
steele doubted the credibility of his
sub source and get this
comey's fisa renewal straight up lied
straight
up lied about carter page and his
connection to the cia and one of comey's
lawyers
fraudulently changed the document to
remove the fact that page
well was actually a source for the cia
and instead said
he was not a source but remember comey
told us all
that any claims of bison abuse or just
utter
nonsense this is a lie what we're about
to show you look
at total confidence that the fisa
process
was followed and that the entire case
was handled in a thoughtful responsible
way by doj
and the fbi i think the notion that
pfizer was abused here is
nonsense nonsense yet another lie comey
knew the dirty dossier was garbage he
knew it was full of unverifiable rumors
and speculation he was warned multiple
times and even christopher steele
under oath when he heard this he should
have gone back because the law requires
us
said i have no idea if any of it's true
that's why he repeatedly denied
that it was used as the bulk of
information in the fisa applications
that we now know also is a lie that
means nunes was right
that means the grassley graham memo was
right and that means that
the shift show adam schiff the
congenital liar
lied repeatedly too take a look
you called the dossier unverified
salacious
why did you use that to define the court
to ask for surveillance for
carter page not only used it but you led
with it
a bulk of that fisa application deals
with that dossier
why yeah that's not my recollection
brett and i don't know that the fisa
application has been released my
recollection was it was part of
a broader mosaic of facts that were laid
before the fisa judge to obtain a
fisa warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the fisa application my
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about
paige and why there was probable cause
to believe he was an agent of a foreign
power and the dossier
was part of that but was not all of it
or a critical part of it
my recollection wasn't a critical part
it basically was everything
another lie inspector general finding
that the dirty dossier
was the central and essential piece of
the fisa application
but like any self-righteous habitual
liar comey just can't come to terms with
the truth
watch this clip from over the weekend
take a look
you don't see a difference between it's
part of a broader mosaic and it was the
played an essential role in establishing
probable
cause it was one of a bunch of different
facts that were assembled to apply to
the court it was the one that convinced
the lawyers that they had enough now
with that added to the pile to go
forward did you know
that the fbi had talked to the russian
contact and he said what steele said
he had he had told him was not true did
you know this you're the fbi director
first again the report will speak for
itself i don't believe the fbi concluded
that steele's reporting was bunk after
talking to a sub source inspector
general did not find misconduct by any
fbi people he found
mistakes and negligent and oversight no
no that's not true in the case of kevin
klein smith he has referred it for a
criminal investigation
right but that's not been resolved this
business with the lawyer changing some
email to a partner on the team
now in case you're wondering comey is
not having a psychotic break from
reality he's just
lying like he usually does through his
teeth and as fox news legal analyst greg
jarrett pointed
out in his best seller witch hunt these
lies are just the tip of the iceberg
first
as fbi director look at this comey
repeatedly reassured
donald trump that he was not a suspect
in the counter intel investigation of
russia a lie
remember in the spring of 2018 comey
claimed he still had no idea who funded
steele's dossier
lie before he was ultimately fired comey
told the president
he doesn't leak and he doesn't do weasel
moves
that was a lie too in fact comey leaked
government memos
detailing meetings and conversations
with the president of the united states
and special counsel horowitz well in
this case the inspector general referred
him
to the doj remember for criminal
prosecution over leaking
and lack of candor make no mistake there
is a very
real human cost to all of these lies
this is the premier law enforcement
agency in the entire world
this entire russia witch-hunt that put
this country through nearly three years
of hell
carter page's reputation utterly
destroyed
illegally spied on his civil liberties
violated his civil rights they didn't
exist
constitutional rights non-existent op-ed
by law professor jonathan turley
an apology to carter page details the
reckless
nonstop smear of a private citizen
all because of comey's fraudulent pies
application
and let's not forget about lieutenant
general michael flynn how could we
forget what comey did to a 33-year
veteran
and as a part of comey's deceitful
investigation and all things trump
what did he do he brags remember first
it was andrew mccabe saying oh no you
don't need a lawyer
but he brags james comey brags he sets
up an american war hero
hero oh i'd never do this in the uh or
try this in the bush
or obama years now i wouldn't even dare
do that watch this
you look at this white house now and
it's hard to imagine two fbi agents
ending up in the sit room how did that
happen
i sent them
something we i probably wouldn't have
done or maybe gotten away with
in a more organized investigation a more
organized administration
in the george w bush administration for
example or the obama administration
and in both of those administrations
there was process and so if the fbi
wanted to send agents into the white
house itself
to interview a senior official you would
work through the white house council and
there'd be discussions and approvals and
who would be there
and i thought it's early enough let's
just send a couple guys over
well i wouldn't do this in these other
administrations um
is this the higher loyalty that you
claim to
possess jim because is that how you
treat a 33-year veteran of this country
served in combat jim now that just shows
you to be
so deceptive narcissistic and yeah
you're a liar
don't forget jim comey also signs the
first prize application
verified october 2016 goes to trump
tower 2017
oh it's salacious but unverified
president-elect lie again
and he signs two more fisa applications
verified
he lies and the great irony of all of
this
it was lieutenant general flynn not
comey who now faces
years behind bars for lying when the
fbi didn't even think he was lying but
they were going after his kid and he was
bankrupt
oh let's see you're going to prosecute
my son or i fall on the sword i'm
shocked
at general flynn's decision without a
doubt comey played a central role
in what is the weaponization of these
most
powerful tools that we entrust to our
government
and they turn them against we the people
and he didn't act alone
let's see what former cia director john
brennan
uh another notorious liar let's see what
role he's played in all of this i can't
wait to get to the bottom of that
according to multiple sources he
strongly advocated
for hillary clinton's bought and paid
for dirty dossier to be included in the
official
u.s intel assessment time will tell the
inspector general horowitz confirmed
this fact in his report
because in 2017 we do know this brennan
clearly lied to congress
when he said the exact opposite take a
look
do you know if the bureau ever relied on
the steele dossier as
any as part of any court filings
applications petitions pleadings i have
no awareness
did the cia rely on it no why not
[Music]
because we we didn't it wasn't part of
the corpus of intelligence
uh information that we had it was not in
any way
used as a basis for the intelligence
community assessment that was done
uh it was it was not
just wondering what prosecutor durham
attorney general barb
they seem to know an awful lot about
this that we will learn in the days and
weeks ahead remember
the same former cia director used his
important status to push baseless
harmful conspiracy theories against the
president of the united states
repeatedly take a look
i think he's afraid of the president of
russia why well
i think one can speculate as to why that
the russians may have something on him
personally
that they could always roll out and make
his life more difficult
clearly i think it's important for us to
be able to improve relations with russia
but the fact that he has has had this
fawning attitude toward mr putin
has not said anything negative about him
i think continues to
you know say to me that he does have
something to fear
lies deceptions hoax conspiracy theories
rumors speculation conjecture
two of america's most powerful
bureaucrats abused
the power they spread false information
they tried to
undo a presidential election
and they got caught